hi good morning John it's Hank
it's IDEs Friday it's Friday October hmm
god I can't help my pocket computer 216
so we got the Hangout Ayumi at
Minneapolis at nerdcon there's a very
brief interaction between us at the end
of the most recent episode of dear Hank
and John if you didn't know we have it
up as we have a podcast it's called dear
Hank and John we answer your questions
and give you Dubes advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon feel like I'm too tall I
feel like I set the camera off too low
there we go hey now all the way down
here alright now cheers real low though
I feel silly now I got one knees all
right on up
oh yeah so now it kind of looked really
great I've been literally sitting here a
today nerdcon stuff but we're throwing
some of it up on the YouTube channel so
the people who weren't there can see it
and people who were that could
experience it again which I'm getting to
do as I ended it it's really enjoyable I
mean I do like to edit video it turns
out that's a nice thing after eight
years of doing something to realize I
quite like this I knew that I liked
making videos like I like I'm like
writing them and getting it up on the
internet and like looking at people
looking at my thing but actually realize
that I like the ending part the sitting
and the clicking by myself I like the
other parts the loud parts with the
interaction and the people and everybody
watch it I also like it quiet
like quiet times just me and my computer
whose name is Greg practical computer hi
Greg how you doing oh I know
always the same just make it that small
noise of you cooling yourself off Greg's
a hot he's hiding I came away from
nerdcon thinking a lot of different
things with a lot of different like I
did these are video ideas and as you can
tell right now by the fact that we're
quite a ways in how to really talk about
anything I don't know which one to pick
so instead of just Google one of those
videos where I scream at you and nothing
happens okay
a thing talking to Paulo butchy gallupi
one of the favorite authors
buddies what my god I fear that's his
there's one this one ship breaker I
think the one a thing
one staff pick and they'll think it may
have one a what I want a prince serve in
a prince honoree I'm not sure doesn't
really matter
if it was a staff pick though at
Shakespeare Company in Missoula Montana
which you should go to if you ever have
a chance because local bookstores part
of the fabric that holds a community
together think about that next time you
on Amazon or I'm on Amazon buying cat
litter well the most recent thing I
bought on Amazon I'm curious to find out
the most recent thing uh again a speaker
for you it doesn't smell great cuz it
was in the dirty laundry but here it is
it's mine oh it's Becky shirts and one
of my very favorite internet things
that's happened on the Internet no it's
Becky right up there with Amos Georg I
love Venus Georg so much has bettered
back to my normal sort of low level of
sting anyway I was talking to Paolo
Bacigalupi and we had this great
conversation about how the for the
format's that are available to us tend
to actually influence the stories that
get told like for ages the only video
formats we had were the 30 minute
episode the 60 minute episode and the
movie length thing but because YouTube
happened suddenly there was this new
format that was available to people in
this format wasn't influenced by when
advertising was gonna show despite the
weirdness of dividing a day in the 24
pieces and saying like each one of these
that's gonna be the length of a TV
episode and it was influenced just by
what's the best possible format for
telling a quick story or make it a quick
thing and so suddenly in 2007 year the
VAR burners being like we can never make
a video more than four minutes long
we're gonna impose that artificial
restriction on ourselves just like we
did when we decided as the culture the
days we're gonna have 24 hunk it's all
arbitrary and it's weird and it's great
that we can't stuck with that and like
this is the format and now that I have
to say despite the fact that I only just
got to the point I have to end this
video because as I said we imposed an
arbitrary distinction upon ourselves and
we must enforce it John I'll see you on
Tuesday